like I told you 15 years ago the next
level is coming
we'll be right back nobody leaves Jeff
do you could go Vinnie chase are you go
I hear you got something for me my first
movie as studio head and boom I want you
to star on it whatever I do next I also
wanted the rat alright Steven I today
all right
holy what Ronda Rousey the fighter I
love her we know each other remember me
didn't she's be really fast get this
movie tanks Vince will not come back
from this neither will i and neither
will you this could get ugly trust me
it's all good oh my god says she's gonna
pop any second what's wrong we got a sex
tape oh god I'm getting married oh god
we need more money right oh god I gave
you a hundred million dollars you agreed
to not go over because you said I
couldn't direct unless we agreed it's
like when a girl asks if you want to
bang her hot sister of course you say no
neither of you really believes you mean
it though what is he doing here
open the door yo Vinnie what's the
matter you girl for lock you out of that
anyone no my co-financier you serious my
boys will break that doing right now I
got the histories crazy I'm crazy take
me for around I last thirty seconds you
let me take you out on a date last 60
seconds I'll
how much done three seconds I'm going to
take you to step